It's now time to wrap up this video tutorial series on an introduction to Unreal.
We started with looking at the Unreal Engine 5 documentation.
Remember that's the best place to get any help you need with any of the various features
or tools that Unreal Engine 5 provides.
We then took a look at what we can use the Epic Games Launcher for.
Remember we used that to download various versions of Unreal Engine as well as access
our Fav library.
We then looked at how Unreal Engine projects are structured because they're working a slightly
different way than we might be used to using multiple project specific files.
We then took a look at the Unreal content pipeline and how we can get various pieces
of content into the editor so that we can work with them in whatever project we're creating.
We took a look at the editor UI.
We covered what actors are.
Then we took a look at the various tools and features that Unreal Engine 5 provides
and how you might be able to utilize those in whatever it is you're creating.
So that's it.
That's going to wrap up this video tutorial series.
Thanks for watching and I'll see you next time.